-Our next guest is a four-time
Tony Award-winning actor,
playwright, and cultural icon
you know from his work
in "Hairspray"
and "Mrs. Doubtfire."
is memoir, "I Was Better
Last Night," is available now.
Please welcome to the show
Harvey Fierstein, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Harvey, I am so happy
you're here!
-I haven't seen people
in a very long time.
They haven't changed, though.
-They haven't changed.
-No, they look like people.
-They still love you.
They still love you.
-You know, 'cause I live
in a small, fictional town
in Connecticut,
so we don't see people there.
We have pictures of people.
-When did you -- Now,
have you always had a place
in this small, fictional town,
or did you get it during COVID?
-No, no, no.
I moved there in '84.
-Oh, my God.
-I've been there a long time.
-Oh, fantastic.
-Yeah.
-Excellent.
-Long time.
-What is it like, though,
when you walk
around the Theater District
in New York City?
Are people just so happy
to see you?
-Yeah, sort of.
I think I've been there so long,
it's like,
"Oh, he's still alive?
We're okay."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"It's gonna be fine.
"Fierstein's still here.
We got a show to see."
[ Laughter ]
-Speaking of Broadway,
I know you're aware of this.
I have been percolating an idea
for a Broadway show
that I'm gonna write, a musical
called "Cicada, Cicada."
[ Light laughter ]
In it, Christine Baranski,
who's a soft "yes,"
plays a cicada,
who loves Broadway.
And she comes to Broadway,
and there's a New York
Mets-loving cockroach,
and I keep saying
it's played by you.
[ Laughter ]
And you sent these photos,
which I think means --
-[ Laughs ]
-I think means you're a yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you in?
-Seth, I'm what you call
a hard "yes."
[ Laughter ]
-A hard yes!
-I am a hard yes!
-You know,
I heard about the story,
and I ran out
and got that costume.
-Yeah.
-And my brother
came over the house.
I said, "Take a picture of me
in this costume for Seth."
And we did.
And then I turned on the TV,
'cause I had to sign books.
And there was -- What is it?
"Let's Make a Deal."
-Uh-huh.
And you know
they come in costumes?
-Yeah.
-And a guy's
wearing that costume.
I said, "It's a sign.
I got to write to Seth.
It's a sign."
-Well, I'm so happy you're here.
This is great 'cause Nathan Lane
has also shown interest.
-Okay.
-And I think we're gonna
pull this thing together.
-I think so.
-Yeah.
Do we have a composer yet?
-We don't have a composer yet.
-I'll call Cyndi.
-Okay, that's great.
You call Cyndi,
and I think we're gonna get
Tony number five for you.
That's the goal here --
Tony number five.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you are a man
who is full of great stories,
and yet you just wrote
your memoir.
What was the delay, and what
made you decide to do it?
-'Cause I cleared my desk
during COVID
and I did the laundry...
and I had nothing to do.
[ Laughter ]
And my agent said,
"Why don't you write a book?"
And I said, "Okay."
[ Laughter ]
Well, you know,
'cause on computers,
you don't even
have to use the paper.
-Yeah.
-So I said -- So I sat down
and I wrote the first story
that's in -- Not the foreword,
but the story where I'm sitting
in second grade
and they made me play --
In "Sleeping Beauty,"
they made me play the King.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I didn't want
to play the King.
-No, you didn't want
to play that.
-I didn't want to play the King.
-No.
-'Cause all he got was
a Reynolds Wrap crown.
-Yeah.
-And a bedspread
that you had to drag behind you.
But my friend Philomena Marano,
she played the evil witch.
-Uh-huh.
-And she got green skin
and red lipstick.
And we went to
the penny-candy store
and got her
those long, black nails.
I wanted to play
the evil witch so bad.
-Yeah.
-So bad.
So I wrote the whole story.
And I said, "Does anybody care?"
So I took the story
and I sent it to Philomena.
-You're still in touch
with Philomena?
-We've been friends
since kindergarten.
-Love it.
-Oh, I don't let friends go.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause they can tell stories
on you. I'm telling ya.
[ Laughter ]
So, I sent it to Philomena.
She sent back the photograph
that's in the book!
She had the photograph.
-Of you as a 7-year-old?
-Me as a 7-year-old
in full drag.
-Well, fantastic.
-For Halloween.
-That's wonderful.
Because, yeah, the following
Halloween, you were like,
"I got to play the King
in the show.
You may be the Queen, but I'll
be the Queen for Halloween."
-So I was --
I dressed up in female clothes,
but I sort of messed up my face,
so I'd look like a zombie,
which made it
a socially acceptable drag.
-Right.
-And she came as a bum.
-There you go.
-In male drag.
-So you talk a little bit about
what was socially acceptable,
the way people talked
about things back then.
You never thought about coming
to Broadway as a life.
But people talked about you.
You wanted to be artistic,
right?
Like, "artistic"
was a word people used.
-Yes, that was --
that meant "gay."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That was polite for "gay."
-That was polite for "gay"
back in the day.
-Before the '50s,
like, in the '40s,
I think it was
"polite," I think.
It might have been the word
for "gay."
[ Laughter ]
Then it became "artistic,"
then it became "sensitive,"
and then it became...stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-And you were here
for all of it.
You lived through all of it.
-Yeah, exactly.
-So, you --
you talk in the book
about you auditioned for,
and were cast in,
an Andy Warhol play.
-Well, I was
an artistic person.
I was working at
a community theater.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So -- and I was working
at a community theater.
And in "Showbiz," the paper,
there was an ad
for Andy Warhol doing a play.
I loved Warhol.
Now, I didn't really like
the pop art yet,
but he used to do
the illustrations
for Bloomingdale's.
-Yeah, beautiful.
He was a wonderful
advertising artist.
-Oh, unbelievable.
So I said, "Wait a second.
I'm in a community theater.
I'm like an actor."
So I asked my friend,
Irene Stein,
she took a photograph of me.
I had to develop it
in my basement
'cause I was artistic.
[ Laughter ]
And then I wrote up a résumé,
and I stapled it together.
And all of a sudden,
I had an 8x10 and a résumé,
and off I went
to meet Andy Warhol.
-And?
-I got in the show.
-That's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So all of a sudden,
I was "a actor."
-That's wonderful.
So, that was it.
-I never planned
on being "a actor."
And then they put me in a dress,
so I felt very at home.
-That's wonderful.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of your relationship
to Broadway --
and before we move on
to some of your film work --
you're working on "Funny Girl"
right now, which is so exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
We did it first in London.
-Mm-hmm.
-Oh, Sheridan Smith
was wonderful.
We did it in London.
It was a big hit.
And then it ran for a year,
and then it toured,
and then we were supposed
to come here, And then COVID.
[ Laughter ]
So now we're finally
getting to do it,
and it's very exciting.
It's in rehearsal.
Beanie said she's coming here.
-Yeah, we're gonna
have Beanie here.
I can't wait, I can't wait.
I can't wait to see it.
-And Jane Lynch.
-What a cast.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What a cast.
-Yeah.
-You talk about a person
who is really special to you,
and I think special
to all of us,
even those who didn't meet him.
Robin Williams.
You played --
-You just want me to cry.
-No, I don't.
I promise,
I don't want you to cry.
But I would like you to tell
the very funny story
of how that role came to you.
Because oftentimes people
see you doing fantastic
in front of an audience,
and they think,
"I have to have this person,"
but that's not what happened.
-That's not how life is.
-No.
Especially for comedians.
-Yeah.
-So I was asked to do --
Lily Tomlin asked me
to do a benefit with her
and Robin Williams
to raise money for this movie
they were -- a documentary.
And I thought I just had
to introduce them,
but when I got there, they said,
"No, no, no,
you have to do
a half-hour of stand-up."
I said, "But I ain't got
no half-hour of stand-up."
And they said,
"Well, just say something."
So I looked at my bag.
I was filming a movie
with Alicia Witt,
and I had no clothes with me,
but I had, like, plaid shirts
and dungarees or whatever.
I said, "I'll do
a lesbian fashion show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"This is San Francisco.
This is gonna be gangbusters."
-Sure, you thought
you had a hit.
-I thought, "Oh,
this is gonna go over big."
They had to send guards
to get me out of town.
[ Laughter ]
And I was so bad,
and they hated me so much,
they just kept booing.
They couldn't even
hear the jokes.
They just were booing.
And Robin stood in the wings,
watching,
'cause as a stand-up comic,
he knew what it was like
to bomb like that.
-Yes.
-And I just kept looking over,
and he's laughing.
And in the other wings,
Lily is laughing,
and I said,
"Oh, this is great."
So I lived through that night.
I mean, Lily at one point said,
"Harvey, could you bring me
a glass of water?"
She was out onstage.
So I came out
with a glass of water.
The newspaper said I tried
to upstage her
by bringing her
a glass of water.
[ Laughter ]
That's how bad it went.
Anyway, the next day,
I got a phone call saying,
"You want to play my brother?"
-And that's how
"Mrs. Doubtfire" came to be.
-Unbelievable.
Well, what a special person.
And you are, too.
And let me tell you,
having you here tonight --
I mean, obviously,
we're gonna work together a lot
on "Cicada, Cicada"...
[ Laughter ]
...but having you here tonight
was deeply special to me.
Thank you so much.
And congratulations
on your memoir.
-Thank you for having me.
-You guys,
that's Harvey Fierstein.
His memoir, "I Was Better
Last Night," is on sale now.